i'm finishes baby beetlejuice
is he the number one whack packer of all
time that's a good question
is it hank the angry drunken dwarf was
it eric the actor
everybody has their opinion i certainly
have mine but as you know i have to
remain impartial
after all i am the host the first time i
met beetle
beetle showed up with a guy they booked
one of the little people on our show
but it wasn't beat beat was just in the
green room my new buddy
beetlejuice i just happened to walk by
i looked in the room and i saw a beat
there it was like
you know when the room goes dark and
there's just a bright light a spotlight
on a person i went
this guy's a star and i brought him in
and he was
a hit seeing beetlejuice is definitely
the highlight of my life
how old are you me i'm 48. wow really
what i would have thought you were a kid
is he really 48
yeah you're 48 beetlejuice yeah really
you have a young face i think you're
going to live a long time
aren't you lucky of course the rest is
history we have beetlejuice on
all the time we could be with the golf
club like tiger woods
he's got a sleeping bag for some reason
i don't even know why
why are you wearing a crown because i'm
a king brother you're the king
i don't think in the history of this
show i ever said to
beetlejuice's manager beat can't come in
we're busy
i don't care who was booked i moved them
aside for beetlejuice you're just gonna
ride a motorcycle in
oh god you didn't hear this
and the name beetlejuice up until then i
remember beetlejuice was the michael
keaton movie it was a good movie
tim burton directed but then you hear
the name beetlejuice now and you're a
fan of this show
you don't think about the movies you
think about beetlejuice
he's one of a kind he's an icon he's
written songs
he's entertained us with costumes here
he comes he's dressed as a monster for
in honor of the movie evolution
you didn't see him before look at him
monster with the gangsta lean
yeah they told me beetlejuice was going
to be in the same paddy's day parade and
i expected you to be wearing a great
outfit and you are
you are dressed as uncle sam you look
fantastic you don't look good you look
great
thank you i'm an article you look oh
you're oracle
sparkle beetlejuice like madonna you've
always changed your image
you always reinvent yourself yeah if
you're wearing a weightlifting belt your
fatigues are open to your belly button
yeah he's showing his chest
he's showing a lot of chest it's just is
this you the sex symbol now
yeah hey beach dressed like the pope wow
cardinals cardinal cardinal beetlejuice
beetle you in there who are you i'm
trying to start
[Laughter]
is it hard to talk through that mask
you've always come up with the best
stuff he talks about anything
you look great man this is a whole new
year
yeah what is the suit and the nice
shirt where did you get these clothes
where did you get them oh i bought them
i brought them you bought them yeah and
uh you
are here to announce that you would like
to be the head of security here at
sirius could be yeah why you don't think
ronnie the limo driver knows what he's
doing
he's a piece of garbage what happened
between you you've been having fights
with some people here especially ronnie
what happened with you and ron
ah ronnie is just like a piece of [ __ ]
you don't need him he brags about stuff
someone told me when they did the
pre-interview you claim you now have hit
one million dollars in your bank account
oh yeah beagle is a millionaire
yeah i ate about four million dollars
honey four four
four million dollars you want to go out
yeah
i'll thank you and the beautiful thing
about beetle he hasn't changed over the
years
the same guy who walked into my studio
originally is the same
guy you get on the air to this day i
love you
i think you're a great guy you've always
contributed to the show
right and i want to thank you for that
right and i want to thank you for taking
care of yourself and i wish you a
hundred more years of life
i truly do i'm gonna keep on doing it my
life is already
up but i'm still living and i've known
you for 50 years or something like this
and i hope i know you for 50 more b
i wish you the best i truly do you know
i'm always there for you if you need
today you know i'm here
never has such a man cast such a wide
shadow
over this show as beetlejuice the legend
[Music]
david spade is a big fan of yours this
is david spade
what's up buddy he's a big fan of yours
yeah he is he wanted to meet you
all you criminals out there beware when
you show us
about that we see us come and run for
the hill vote for your life
cause me and bill just gonna keep the
streets right yeah street clean brother
thank you beet you're the best thanks
for all the years of
entertainment and uh we love you on this
show i love you i love you have a start
[Music]
door baby beetlejuice say the word